ما العلاقه بين الكبسه وكره القدم العلاقه
تاتينا من المعلومات التي زودنا بها ليث
بازاري من الدوحه وهي ان المنتخب المكسيكي
طلب تناول الكبسه السعوديه قبل المباراه
المرتقبه اليوم طبعا الفكاهه السعوديه
سارعه الاعتبار ذلك مؤشر جيد لان دسامه
الكبسه كفيله بالحد من اداء المكسيكيه وفي
كل الاحوال بالعزيمه والروح والاصرار
سيدخل لاعب المنتخب السعودي
في المباراه الحاسمه هذه الليله والاخضر
عينه على التاهل الدوري 16 اذا سلح الاخضر
بعامل الدعم الكبير من جماهيره التي
تتواجد الى ستاند سيل فيما قد يكون
التعادل كافيا للاخضر ايضا شرقي فوز
الارجنتين او بولندا بنتيجه تتجاوز
الهدفين لاحدهم
على كل حال الى لقاء السعوديه والمكسيك
ونذكر ايضا بالفيديو الذي انتشر في السوشل
ميديا تيكي تيكي سنقضي على المكسيكي
بالارقام نتعرف على احصائيات الاخضر
السعودي ونظيره المكسيكي في تاريخ
المشاركات بكاس العالم ست مرات وصل
المنتخب السعودي الى نهائيات كاس العالم
كان اخرها في النسخه الحاليه سبعه عشره
مره ترك المنتخب المكسيكي في نهائيات كاس
العالم اخرها ايضا النسخه الحاليه في قطر
مره وحيده تاهل فيها المنتخب السعودي لدور
السادس عشر في مونديال الولايات المتحده
عام
1990 مره وصلت من المنتخب المكسيكي الى
الدور الربع النهائي لكاس العالم في
نسختين اللتين اصطفتهما المكسيك اربع
انتصارات حققتها السعوديه في تاريخ
مشاركاتها بكاس العالم 16 انتصارا حققها
المكسيك خلال مشاركتها السابقه في نهائيات
كاس العالم على كل حال ان الناس في
السعوديه كيف يتوقعون مباراه بين الاخضر
ونظيره المكسيكي
[تصفيق]
برشلونه
مع الاهل في البيت وتوقعاتنا ان شاء الله
فوز المنتخب السعودي
طيب ان شاء الله خير يا رب موفقين المنتخب
الله يسعدك جميعا ان شاء الله وفي
المباراه ان شاء الله هذه باذن الله ان
شاء الله يفوز بهدف او هدفين ويتاهل
الدوره الثانيه
والقران ان شاء الله الفوز باذن الله
ونتمنى ان شاء الله اثنين واحد ان شاء
الله باذن الله وان شاء الله نتبعها ان
شاء الله مع الاهل اتوقع 2-0 للسعودين ان
شاء الله
والله تعبان ان شاء الله
نشوف النتيجه
[موسيقى]
من الرياض ينضم الينا مراسله صباح العربيه
اسامه القاسم اسامه يسعد صباحك اهلا بيكم
مباريات حسيمه اليوم كيف تبدو الاجواء قبل
المباريات خصوصا مباراه السعوديه المكسيك
وعلى جميع المشاهدين قناه العربيه
بالتاكيد اليوم نتحدث عن مباراه ملحميه
مباراه تاريخيه للمنتخب السعودي ضمن دوري
المجموعات في تصفيات دور المجموعات كاس
العالم 22 والمقام في قطر المنتخب السعودي
اليوم امام فرصه تاريخيه للوصول الى دوري
16 لتاني مره في تاريخه ما هي الاشياء
التي يمكن ان نقول عنها مؤهله للمنتخب
السعودي ما هي نقاط القوه التي تتواجد لدى
الصقور الخضر اليوم في مباراتها الثالثه
في تصفيات دور المجموعات المنتخب السعودي
يلعب مباراته اليوم لاجل الفوز لا ينظر
الى النتائج الاخرى في مباراه بولندا
والارجنتين المنتخب السعودي اليوم ايضا
امام فرصه تاريخيه الوصول ثاني مره الى
دور السته عشر حيث سبق انجازه عام
1994 اما الاجواء هنا الاجواء اليوم بكل
امانه من ثلاثه ايام والاجواء حماسيه
الاجواء عاليه جدا عالي الناس كلها قاعده
مجريات المباريات ينتظرون هذه المباراه
بفارق الصبر كره القدم هنا في السعوديه
ليست مجرد نعم
اسامه وقت مباراه الارجنتين والسعوديه
اللي فازت فيها السعوديه على الارجنتين
زملاء كثر وزميلتنا ميس الحربي من الحدث
ارسلت لي فيديوهات عده يعني عملها سعوديين
حول هذا الفوز لمس جانب من الدم الخفيف
يعني في هذه الفيديوهات بشكل كبير يعني ما
كنت انا شايفته لك شو في طرائف هلا اليوم
محضرين هالسعوديين همم غنى معين همم
شعارات معينه محضرينها لمباراه اليوم مع
المكسيك
شوفي ايه اولا خليني اتكلم بشكل واقع
السعوديين متفائلين جدا اليوم في منتخبهم
ومنتخب قوي جدا تقريبا هو اقوى منتخب خلال
اخر 20 سنه الوصول له سته عشر ناس كثير
ممكن ما لحقت انا واحد منهم يعني انا همم
يعني ما لحقت تاهل المنتخب 1994 فانا من
امنيات الكبيره انه انا اعيش في المنتخب
اليوم 16
ههه لا بعد هذا شيء ثاني لكن اتكلم اليوم
ايضا عن الطرائف يعني امس وانا اتصفح
تويتر في كثير كاتبين رسائل لمدراهم في
العمل انه شكرا مدير انه انت خليتني اطلع
كاس العالم في قطر الناس اليوم عايشه نوع
من شعور الفخر بهذا المنتخب وايضا نوع من
ال- ال- الحماس الكروي كما سبقت انه الكره
القدم في السعوديه ليست مجرد كره قدم هي
اكبر من ذلك الكتاب
يبقى هنا في السعوديه بالنسبه للمتابعات
مشاهدات سواء التواصل الاجتماعي وحتى اي
برامج مباريات كره القدم السعوديه اليوم
تضوج باللون الاخضر جميع المقاهي المناطق
التي همم تنقل مباريات كاس العالم هذه
الساحه ايضا احدى المناطق ال 39 في
الرياضه التي تنقل مباريات كاس العالم
السعوديه اليوم كما اسبقت امام منجز
تاريخي حول الله تعالى انه يكون الفوز
حاليا في الصقور الخضر نرجع يعني
المباريات السابقه للسعوديه والمكسيك
السعوديه واجهت خمس مباريات لم تنتصر فيها
كلها باستلم المكسيك في اربع وصار التعادل
في مباراه واحده لكن يوم كما سبقت حدود
المنتخب السعودي كبيره جدا المنتخب يلعب
على لاجل الفوز همم المدرب اليوم تقريبا
التشكيله اصبحت واضحه لن يكون هناك الا
تبديلين في مركز الظهير ومركز المحور وهذا
الشيء يعطى المنتخب السعودي قوه كبيره جدا
المنتخب السعودي امام الارجنتين لعب
بدفاعه وهجوم متوازي بينما في مباراه
بولندا لعب بهجوم كبير جدا ولكن كان اللعب
بشكل كبير جدا المنتخب السعودي يعني
تقريبا كان الاستحواذ فوق 60% وهي يعني
تعتبر نسبه كبيره جدا في مباراه كاس عالم
اليوم السعوديين بكل امانه على احر من
الجمر ينتظرون هذه المباراه اتصور انه لو
فاز المنتخب السعودي سوف تكون الرياض يعني
فوق ما هي خطره هتكون اكثر اضرارا
السعوديه كلها بكل مناطقها اليوم امام همم
يعني مصير كبير جدا لكن تتخيل انه كيف
السعوديه
اول متوسط 16 80% من الموجودين اليوم ما
لحقوا انجاز 94 فبالتالي هذه انجاز
اعتبرهم شيء كبير جدا خصوصا المنتخب غاب
عن كاس العالم انه هيك عن التصفيات في عام
2006 و 2010 و2014 وما كان مشاركه جيد في
2018 هذه المشاركه المشاركه تاريخيه على
مستوى اللعب وايضا نتمنى بحاول يتعلموا
يحالفهم الفوز همم ايضا اعيد انه المناطق
ال 39 التي تبث مباريات كاس العالم مناطق
مهيئه بالكامل من قبل امانه الرياض
والجهات ايضا للمشاركه المشجعين كثر جدا
المناطق ايضا همم اصبحت من الان بالنسبه
للمناطق المحجوزه ما لقى بالكامل كل
الاماكن حجوزات غير الاماكن اللي موجوده
الان همم اليوم ايضا الجهات تبدي
استعدادها الكامل لبث مباراه المنتخب
نتمنى بالتاكيد انه الفوز همم
واحنا معك يا الاخضر شكرا لك يا اسامه
يعني انا بدي اسمع ايضا توقعاتكم انتم
مباريات المنتخب المكسيك اليمامه رساله
توقف فوز المنتخب حول تعالى واختمها ايضا
توقعاتكم في الاسبوع
يعني لما بنحكي عن امريكا الجنوبيه هم
الاساس كره القدم فما لازم نستهين فيهم
اتوقع انه راح يكون في ممكن تعادل اثنين
اثنين منتخب السعودي فان الفوز دائما
اسامه القاسم صباح العربيه